ich glaube es bewegt so viele Menschen
mit der Traum nach dem Eigenheim der ja
momentan zu platzen droht
spreche da aus leidlicher Erfahrung in
dem Berufsalltag wir beraten Menschen in
den vielen finanziellen Fragestellungen
planen die Träume werden realisiert man
spart Eigenkapital an die letzten Jahre
grotesk ja man hat nichts gefunden also
die Leute haben gesucht die Waren im
staatlichern die haben noch Bauplätzen
geschaut ja nach Bestandsimmobilien
geschah zwar nichts auf dem Markt oder
wenn dann zu Preisen wo man stark die
Zellen zusammenbeißen musste und dann
kam diese Zinswende angetrieben durch
natürlich den Krieg die Inflation und so
weiter und zwar notwendige Zinsen zu
erhöhen also ich glaube es ist
unbestritten dass die Zinsen nicht
die Schuld sind warum jetzt die
Immobilien nicht mehr leisten können so
eine Grund ist natürlich dass die Preise
nicht im Gegenzug sinken ja dass wir
kein Potenzial haben den Gegenspieler so
wie es am meisten niedrig
Immobilienpreise steigen vereinfacht
dargestellt und andersrum sondern die
die Preiskurve geht nicht in dem Maß
nach unten wie es nötig wäre und mit
diesem Zinsniveau das eigentlich
normales Zinsniveau ist immer mal auf
die Historie zurückblickt
immobilienleisten zu können und da
müssen wir ansetzen das ist
entscheidende Punkt wo wo die ganzen
Player die die da eine Rolle spielen die
Politik die Bürger die
Erwartungshaltungen an der Stelle
einfach jetzt eingreifen müssen und da
die richtigen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
oder sonst bleiben noch da stehen wo man
sind die Deutschen haben ungefähr 46 %
wohnen Eigentum dessen europäischen
Vergleich viel zu wenig und deswegen 43%
damit haben wir den vorletzten Platz vor
der Schweiz aber ich finde eine Sache
ganz ganz spannend weil ich habe mir
natürlich die Zahlen angeschaut und mit
knapp 96% wohnen Eigentumsquote liegt
Rumänien im vielleicht ganz vorn aber
Rumänien steht ja eigentlich nicht für
Reichtum es hat auch nicht zwingend nur
mit Reichtum zum sondern auch mit dem
mit dem also es ist komplexer
als kaufen mit dem Blick auf die Zahlen
in Deutschland momentan ist es
tendenziell so ist auch eine Beratung
die wir machen mal im momentan der
hauptratschlag zu sagen bleiben Miete
nur die Frage ist natürlich immer auch
ist es möglich denkt man an Familien die
Zuwachs bekommen wenn sie dann Wohnraum
zu klein wird oder Eigenbedarfskündigung
bekommen also ist ja nicht immer so dass
man den Mietraum bekommt und da kann man
ja auf das Problem warum die Preise kaum
sein Menschen kaufen
als Beratungsleistung im Prinzip nichts
zwingend weil
die Menschen können wir den Euro nur
eine Sache tun ja entweder investieren
uns in den Immobilien dann haben sie
gekauft sie finanzieren dann machen sie
die Tilgung oder Sie machen Sparplan
also von unserer Philosophie ist es
erstmal tatsächlich egal was sie mit
ihrem Geld tun solange es natürlich mit
uns tun logischerweise aber ob sie dann
Sparpläne machen oder die Mobile ist uns
erstmal deswegen haben wir neutrale
Position an der Stelle muss ich heute
gelernt habe ist jeder soll sich an Sie
wenden für die Finanzen das haben wir
jetzt schon mal gemerkt
den beende ich jetzt mal schnell und
kommt zu
ihnen denn auf die wohneigentumsquoten
das Deutscher mit etwa 43% nur vor der
Schweiz liegt also Sie haben es im
Prinzip schon gesagt wenn man sich mal
die Länder anschaut wo man sehr hohe
wohnen eigentumsquoten hat ja das ist
nicht unbedingt ein positives Zeichen
also die Schweiz ist ein tolles Land und
hat mir noch Eigentumsquote trotzdem
sollte sich jeder der das möchte den
Traum erfüllen können und das Problem
ist ja es wird oft gesagt es liegt an
den Zinsen ja im Moment sind die
vielleicht bei 4%, ich weiß noch wo ich
meine erste Wohnung gekauft habe da war
ich ganz stolz nach meine Freundin
gesagt guck mal ich habe für 7%, das
Fest gemacht weil wir 7%, ganz ganz
niedrig vorkam ja das heißt 4 % sind
immer noch historischen Vergleich
niedrig aber die Preise sind zu hoch und
da muss man sich überlegen wo dran liegt
das und ein Grund ist weil wir einfach
viel zu viele Vorschriften haben die das
Bauen immer teurer machen wir haben
Bauvorschriften und Normen in
Deutschland 25000 ja besonders ganz ganz
viele ökovorschriften die das Bauen
immer immer mal machen ja und dann langt
der Start natürlich auch noch zu also
ich habe ja erzählt wo ich meine erste
Wohnung gekauft habe da war die
Grunderwerbsteuer zwei prozentig gezahlt
habe heute wenn sie in Berlin
Grunderwerbsteuer bezahlen 20 6 1/2
Prozent also das heißt hat sich
verdreifacht der Staat lang kräftig zu
ja und dann werden wir das Sündenböcke
gesucht dann wird gesagt ja der böse
Makler der immobilienerheit der ist
schuld und gegen den müssen wir was tun
nee wir müssen überlegen lieber bauen
auch wieder
entschlacken von Bürokratie und eine
Möglichkeit geben das einfach wesentlich
günstiger gebaut wird und da haben auch
wieder wir haben heute schon einiges auf
über die Grünen gesagt aber natürlich
auch viel grüne Ideologie drin ja dass
man immer denkt wir müssen noch
irgendwas dämmen und wir müssen noch
irgendwas und da und da machen ja und
das hat natürlich alles das unglaublich
teuer so dass das hört sich viele
Menschen einfach den Traum nicht mehr
fühlen können
Sie weitergeben mein Bruder es wird ja
fast als würde die Regierung verhindern
wollen dass die Menschen sich ein
Eigenheim bauen das kannst ja nicht sein
doch das ist offenbar der Fall ich
glaube nicht dass das endlich als Plan
passiert aber so gut dann ist es mit
Sicherheit so unsere Wohnungsbau
Ministerin Frau Gleiwitz so ähnlich
glaube ich ich habe ich habe es mit
Namen Corona spätwirkung der hat jetzt
ein fantastisches
der hat den wahnsinnig guten Vorschlag
gemacht Familien und überhaupt Leute
sollten aus der Stadt Ausland
ja geniale Vorschlag wenn man vergisst
dass man dafür eine Infrastruktur
braucht dass man die Anbindung
herstellen muss zwischen Land und Stadt
dass man auch Arbeitsplätze hat außer
man nimmt für den Leuten hinter zwei
Personen immer wieder und zwar mit dem
Auto ist es haut vorne und hinten nicht
wissen sie es gibt nicht nur kein
Masterplan es gibt überhaupt gar keine
Vorstellung von dem was gemacht werden
muss weil sich dieses Land in kleinen
Krampf verloren hat
Problem ist genau das dass wir nicht
vernetzt sind agieren über die Ressort
hin Beispiel wir haben eine Preis
Inflation gleichzeitig wird die
gründerabsteuern Bayern Sachsen erhöht
dann haben wir jetzt eine unsägliche
Grundsteuerreform wo die ganze Republik
eigentlich rebelliert jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen okay dieses ist vom
bundesgerichtshofen
her aber die Frage ist wie gestalte ich
treffersätze an die immer noch nicht
bekannt sind sondern erst in 25
nachgeschoben worden also wir haben
lauter preisträder politisch gemacht
sind die so gar nicht so Bauwirtschaft
daraus kommen und an die müssen wir ran
und da gibt's ja auch ist immer auf der
Hand liegende Lösungsansätze man könnte
ja hergehen und sagen die
Grunderwerbsteuer runter wir setzen
diese Grundsteuerreform so an dass der
gemäßigt ist
und im Gegenzug wenn man eine
Refinanzierung sucht wir haben nach zehn
Jahre die Steuerfreiheit in der
Immobilie wenn man die Menschen die ihr
Eigenheim suchen ist langfristig für
sich sehen und auch dort den niedersatz
im Alter sehen die wollen ja nicht
verkaufen also kann man ja diese zehn
Jahre mal diskutieren und die muss ja
nicht mit einkommensteuert werden eine
Abgeltungssteuer draufsetzen um das
Ganze gemäßigt zu machen also gibt es
schon Lösungsansätze wo man dann die
Kosten die nicht wertschöpfend sind weil
sie nicht in die mobile investiert
werden in den Griff kriegen könnte und
somit auch das Ganze wieder in den
maßrücken das wäre eine Maßnahme von
Möhren möglichen eine sehr gute Maßnahme
damit schließen wollte wissen am Ende
der Sendung mehr raucht jetzt auch der
Kopf von all den Steuern und Reform und
ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend nächste Woche sitzt hier Patricia
platziert schönen Abend noch wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie